-Guys, today is Thursday.
-Right.
-And that's usually when I catch
up on some personal stuff.
-Really?
-Yeah.
You know, normally
it would be Friday.
-Yeah. I mean, it's Thursday.
-No.
This is the way it works now.
-Oh.
-Thursday is the new Friday.
-You know what I'm saying?
This is like --
-Yeah.
-The weekend longer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What I do is
I get stuff organized.
I clear my desktop,
my virtual desktop.
-Your virtual desktop.
-I go on.
I have a couple virtual
online meetings.
-Right, love that.
[ Laughter ]
-"Hey, good to see you man.
How's it going?"
You know, stuff like that.
My arms are exhausted.
-Oh, my gosh.
-Meeting, meeting, meeting.
And I normally write out actual,
physical thank-you notes
and mail them.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Do you mail them?
-Through the U.S.
Postal Service.
-Wow!
-Yeah.
I use our great
U.S. Postal Service.
You know, I wanted to be
a mailman at one point.
-Did you really?
-I really did.
I was going into comedy, and my
parents go, "We support you,
but please take
the postal exam."
[ Laughter ]
"See if you -- "
'Cause I loved our mailman.
I loved the idea of it.
I loved that he had
a steering wheel
on the other side of the thing.
He's making his own rules.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-And wore shorts.
-Yeah.
-Didn't care.
-Walked around.
-Walked around bringing
good news to people.
-Yeah.
-Right? Sometimes bad news.
-One of the greatest services
of all time.
-But he was there
for the ups and downs.
And I'm prepared for that
mentally.
-With them?
-No, with humans.
I could deliver the bills.
I could give you some bad news.
-"Oh, wow, it's a bill, dang."
Oh, but guess what.
-Guess what. Here's your check.
Yeah, or here's a magazine or,
you know, an L.L. Bean catalog.
-Sure.
-I'll shove it in the mailbox
with love.
-Yeah. "Life" magazine.
-Yeah, I got four crumpled
L.L. Bean catalogs in here.
-And it was raining outside and
it was wet, so they're soggy.
But guess what.
-There you go. But guess what.
-Still love them.
-Yeah, something to do, right?
[ Laughter ]
Gives you something to do. You
go throw it out or recycle it.
-Yeah, or you let it dry,
standing straight up.
-Yeah.
While you're at it, you go,
"Oh, these papers are drying
awfully quick.
There must be a nice draft here.
Maybe I'll get
in the jerky business."
-Oh, my gosh.
-So, you get thin strips --
-Sure. Thin strips.
-You know, you lay it out,
whatever that magazine was.
The breeze goes through.
There you go.
You're making yourself
a whole little business.
-Delicious jerky. Beef jerky.
Tuna jerky. Turkey jerky.
I just like saying it --
turkey jerky.
-Yeah, I love saying it too.
And you know who doesn't
get thanks?
-Who?
-The mailman.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
So next time you're making
jerky, leave some out.
Don't be a jerky and leave
some out for the mailman.
[ Laughter ]
-That's what I'm saying, buddy.
Well, I was running
a bit behind today.
I couldn't write my --
I was just --
If you guys wouldn't mind,
I'd like to write out
my weekly thank-you notes
right now.
Is that okay with you?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you!
James, can I get some thank-you
note writing music, please?
♪♪
-Wow, a lot of 'tude.
-No, he's in a good --
He's in a good mood, man.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, back-to-school ads,
for really cornering
the "children jumping
with backpacks" market.
[ Applause ]
Yay!
♪♪
Thank you, school,
for being a place where we learn
new things and make
everlasting friendships.
But mostly get really good
at drawing this thing.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
-I got an eraser. I'm going to
do it with an eraser.
-Let me see if I can do it.
Mm, mm, mm.
Alright, this is the jam.
You start there.
-Yeah, start there.
That's what you start with.
-Alright.
♪♪
-Triangle.
-Oh, I do this part I think.
-Oh, I see.
Then you can make kind of
the Celtic cross coming up.
I like that. Yeah.
♪♪
Ooh!
[ Audience oohs ]
Oh, wow, it's like 3-D.
♪♪
-There you go.
-Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, whatever.
-That's what I do, whatever.
I'm at a heavy metal concert,
I'm like --
-Yeah, alright.
[ Laughter ]
I studied graphic art.
-Let's get it out of the way.
You know?
-Let's get it done.
-Yeah.
-Rock on, sure.
-I want to appreciate the music.
Don't make me perform.
-Yeah. Do you mind sitting down?
Yeah.
Don't stand up in front of me.
-This out of respect,
and let's go.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
-Thank you, old-school
pencil sharpeners,
for being the only part of
my second grader's classroom
that looks like it belongs in
a "Saw" movie.
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Thank you, Little Caesars
new Crazy Calzony,
for looking like a board game
where the winner
gets high blood pressure.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-It's boiling hot!
♪♪
-Thank you, mid-August,
or as CVS calls you, Halloween.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Now?
♪♪
Thank you, super-long
auto-generated passwords,
for being a great way
to keep hackers and me
out of my account.
[ Cheers and applause ]
This is a safe one.
I know, I know, I know.
-I got to write it down.
-Password123 is just awesome.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Thank you, people who type "Thx"
instead of "thanks,"
for letting me know
that you're feeling grateful
but not grateful enough
to type three extra letters.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thx but no thx.
-I'm too busy.
♪♪
-Thank you, coconuts,
for being juicy, tender fruit
on the inside and porch doormat
on the outside.
There you have it.
Those are our thank-you notes.